ah ah
oh
o o
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui vous anime claude guéant
le service de l'état où l'exercice du
pouvoir
c'est très clairement le service
l'exercice du pouvoir n'est qu'un moyen
de servir oui quand on a eu comme j'ai
eu la chance de la voir des
responsabilités très importante au
satellite al ce qu'on a envie de faire
c'est de rendre service à ses
concitoyens et effectivement on a
l'impression peut-être à tort quelques
fois que l'on rend des services
alors vous étiez parti dans votre vie
pour faire ça parce que vous avez fait
des études vous avez pas selena
oui c'est vrai ce qui n'était pas
évident d'ailleurs parce que vous venez
d'une famille plutôt modeste du pas de
calais oui c'est vrai vous étiez très
fort en anglais alors là c'est une
surprise que j'ai découverte c'est que
vous avez même eu un accessit au
concours général d'anglet et vous avez
brillamment réussi l'ena jeu plutôt bien
réussi oui j'en suis sorti 17e donc
j'avais après est ce qu'il est convenu
d'appeler des grands corps une très
grande latitude de choix et j'ai choisi
le corps préfectoral et pourquoi vous
avez fait sept corps alors j'ai choisi
de corps préfectoral précisément parce
que au cours du stage que pendant la
scolarité j'avais fait en préfecture
c'était la préfecture des deux sèvres je
me souviens j'avais eu très clairement
ce sentiment que l'on pouvait
concrètement aider les gens que l'on
pouvait résoudre des problèmes que l'on
pouvait mener des projets des projets
dont on puisse constater les résultats
alors vous à plaisir j'avais choisi
d'entrée à l'ena avec l'espoir d'être
diplomate
et puis au cours de route j'ai découvert
cette expérience de terrain qui m'a
convaincu qu'il fallait que je gendron
car vous n'êtes pas ces deux préfectures
en préfecture vous avez fait la
guadeloupe 6 obéi c'est exact week de
quoi vous êtes le plus fier dans cette
carrière préfectorale dans cette
carrière préfectorale j'ai une fierté
qui a été quelque chose qui a été
remarqué d'ailleurs que j'ai prouvé lors
de mon dernier poste territorial j'étais
préfet de la région de bretagne et j'ai
beaucoup lutté pour améliorer la qualité
de l'eau et quand je suis parti les
orientations qui avaient été fixés ont
été suivis des c'est comme ça qu'on se
fait remarquer que l'objectif n'est pas
de se faire remarquer l'objectif c'est
de régler des problèmes concrets
parce que la qualité de l'eau en
bretagne allait se dégradant quand ce
qui en soi est est quelque chose de
préoccupant mais qui aussi porter
atteinte au potentiel de développement
de la région et est bien quand même vous
être remarqué parce que vous faites du
cabinet vous faites du cabinet
ministériel et vous entrez notamment au
ministère de l'intérieur mais chez un
breton d'ailleurs c'est christian bonnet
c'est tout à fait exact j'avais choisi
le corps préfectoral je vous le disais
hier un instant pour faire du terrain
ouais
et puis finalement j'aurais passé la
moitié de ma vie à paris en
administration centrale ou en cabinet
effectivement je crois que c'était en
je revenais d'une voix de lou je venais
de vivre l'expérience de l'éruption du
volcan de la soufrière et puis par
l'intermédiaire d'un camarade qui était
déjà au cabinet de christian benêt j'ai
été appelé à son côté et je suis comme
ça pour la première fois j'ai été en
fonction au ministère de l'intérieur
il ya un événement important qui va
marquer votre passage au ministère de
l'intérieur on né le 29 octobre 1979 et
je vous invite à regarder
ceci c'était un homme d'une immense on a
dit et on est mise en cause à la
bouleverser pourtant c'est un homme que
donner l'image d'un solide nerfs d'acier
c'est un geste qui ressemble fort à une
confidence
on a beau et chaud lorsque l'on vient
sur
tag
malgré votre solide
je dirais akono très limitée car
l'équilibré fragile
à cause de cette solitude je crois qu'on
est proche nous sommes bouleversés nous
sommes terrifiés me verrai ton état
inquiète aussi parce que fait on n'a pas
des hommes comme lui ça me paraît très
graves mais attendus en l'avenir on
cherchera des responsabilités il s'agit
de robert boulin exactement robert
boulin qui était ministre du travail
oui et qui est retrouvé mort dans les
étangs de hollande à rambouillet dans la
banlieue de paris grande banlieue de
paris et 12 est le jour de sa mort ou la
nuit' sa mort est bien de permanence ou
ministère de l'intérieur et ces boues
qui recevait la pelle ou enfin pas
exactement à vrai dire c'est l'histoire
qui a été dit le souvenir que j'ai est
tous très légèrement différent à
l'époque le cabinet était dirigée par un
préfet exceptionnelle qui était deux
fois préfet de police jean paolini ouais
et je dois dire que quels que soient les
tours de permanence surtout pour une
affaire comme celle là c'était lui qui
était dérangé c'est lui qui a été
informé mais ce qui est vrai en revanche
c'est que très tôt le matin le ministre
ayant été informé il a rassemblé son
cabinet pour donner l'information qui
est effectivement une information
tragique beaucoup d'égards et dramatique
sur le plan politique
et vous personnellement parce qu'ils
enquêtent d'ailleurs à montrer qui
s'était suicidé mais cette enquête a été
remise en question maintes fois
notamment par ses enfants
la soeur wifi cioni a mené un combat il
a était susi d où il s'est suicidé il
faut raconter un petit peu en deux
secondes
c'est une histoire de terrains
constructibles mais en le var et robert
boulin aurait demandé l'autorisation un
petit peu par la bande au préfet du var
de rendre ce que terrain constructible
avec des échanges d'argent votre intime
conviction sur ce sujet c'est quoi bon
je n'ai qu'une intime conviction je n'ai
pas mené l enquête jeu
hier il enquête se poursuit toujours
d'ailleurs compte tenu des demandes qui
sont faites par la famille de robert
boulin et notamment sa fille
mon intime conviction c'est qu'il s'est
suicidé effectivement eu robert boulin
était un ministre de très très grande
qualité un homme de valeur et je pense
que il n'a pas supporté la perspective
les rendre la politique c'est quand même
violent la politique c'est très souvent
les régissent car des scènes très
violentes trois hommes politiques meurt
dans des circonstances étranges jean de
braye assassiné en 1976
oui robert boulin vous pensez qu'il
s'est suicidé mais c'était en 1960 je
n'ai qu'une intime conviction joseph
fontanet joseph fontanet meurt assassiné
dans le 16e arrondissement en 1981 je me
souviens très bien de l'assassinât de
joseph fontanet christian bonnet qui
avaient beaucoup relations personnelles
avec lui était absolument bouleversés et
je puis dire qu'il a vraiment fait
l'impossible en mobilisant la totalité
des services d enquête pour essayer
d'élucider cette affaire
et cette affaire n'a jamais été élucidé
alors que les circonstances étaient
d'une banalité totale fait vous vous
rendez compte là que l'homme politique
est violente
ah oui mais elle n'est pas violente
seulement dans ces circonstances là elle
est violente tout le temps elle est
violente thouars j'ai je suis tombé en
politique un peu sur le tard
ouais je dois dire que ça n'a rien à
voir entre le fait d'exercer une
responsabilité politique et le fait
d'être un collaborateur de haut niveau
dans un gouvernement
ça n'a rien à voir ça n'a rien à voir au
fonctionnaire et d'être rien à voir je
me souviens quand j'étais ministre un
jour sort dans le nouvel observateur une
information c'était un petit article
selon laquelle j'aurais emmené mes
enfants au cirque le cirque gruss en
période de noël
gratuitement et en plus en bénéficiant
d'une après-midi réservé pour le figaro
bon il n'était rien de tel mais j'ai vu
c'est quand même extraordinaire donné la
photocopie de ma carte bleue donc la
calomnie c'est ça fait pitié intégrante
de la pratique ça fait partie et c'est
vraiment tout à fait insupportable et
alors pour quelles que soient les
personnes quelles que soient les partis
et je dois dire d'ailleurs que cette
violence se trouve entre eux adversaire
si je crains lire mais aussi au sein des
mêmes familles politiques faut plus se
méfier de ses amis que ses ennemis d'une
certaine façon oui parce qu'on ne
s'attend pas à ce que les amis vous
mettre des peaux de banane ou bien monte
des chantiers contre vous alors y'a t il
ya une concurrence ya cette violence
politique que vous décrivez la calomnie
l'opprobre et néanmoins vous étiez haut
fonctionnaire et un jour vous devenez
l'homme le plus puissant de france c'est
un des qualificatifs une des formules
qui a été utilisé à votre votre endroit
on vous a qualifié de vice-président de
premier ministre bis et vous l'avez
assumer ça c'était difficile pour moi de
prendre la parole et de dire non autres
années paraît s'était passablement
ridicule mais bon je veux dire que ces
qualificatifs n'ont pas fait un bien
formidable d'ailleurs ils n'ont pas
amené que des amis mais c'est vrai
qu'avec la façon que nicolas sarkozy
avait d'exercer ses compétences je veux
dire d'ailleurs que le président macron
endosse aussi la totalité des pouvoirs
constitutionnels qui lui sont dévolues
les proches collaborateurs évidemment
prennent une place qui est tout à fait
important dort mais claudia autant que
le président souhaitait que ses plus
proches collaborateurs s'exprime
médiatiquement alors juste ce qui était
nouveau c'est une première c'est une
première qui ne s'est pas reproduite
après donc c'est un internet je dirais
dans l'histoire de la vème république
claude guéant et quelques autres
collaborateurs font des matinales le
matin à la radio à la télévision
participent à des grandes émissions
politiques
vous en êtes un des habitués et c'est
assez étrange parce que là vous vous
quittez votre rôle votre tunique de
collaborateurs et vous devenez un homme
de premier plan
oui alors quand vous dites je me suis
habitué il faut s'habituer ça vous avez
de dire je me souviens une quinzaine de
jours ou trois semaines après que le
président se soit installée et il
m'encourage à faire une émission du
dimanche soir est bon ok ça dure une
heure sur tous les sujets que l'on peut
imaginer
c'était vraiment pour moi une première
m'était arrivé comme préfet de faire
quelques apparitions à la télévision
mais c'était pas pour des exercices de
ce niveau alors pourquoi d'abord le
président le souhaitez ensuite je crois
qu'il ya quand même une justification à
cela la justification ce n'est pas
d'asseoir la prééminence de la
présidence de la république par rapport
à d'autres organismes de l'état par
exemple disons le franchement par
rapport à matignon la justification
c'est que il y a peu de gens dans
l'appareil d'état qui embrasse la
totalité des sujets qui sont traités par
le gouverneur cosy pouvait pas se passer
le président est en état le premier sans
état le secrétaire-général la présidence
le directeur de cabinet du premier
ministre sont aussi des personnages qui
sont en mesure de s'exprimer sur tout ce
que ne fait pas ministres sectoriels
sauf que sauf que quand on est
journaliste et qu'on écrit l'actualité
politique à l'époque on se dit
effectivement françois fillon c'est un
collaborateur et claude guéant sont
hissés l'homme est à la tête est bien de
toute l'organisation du gouvernement
pour nicolas sarkozy
non
disons les choses de façon juste le
secrétaire général de la présidence
nicolas sarkozy d'abord le collaborateur
est en jeu je revendique l'expression du
président de la république
bon c'est pas la peine de se cacher la
vérité effectivement il connaît à peu
près de tout il participe à la
définition des orientations il joue un
rôle dans la mise en oeuvre des
décisions qui sont prises c'est
extrêmement important et d'ailleurs avec
le recul je pense que j'aurais dû jouer
un rôle plus important encore cela est
plus important oui
en dépit des coups que vous avez pu
prendre oui parce que bon on le voit
bien aujourd'hui il apparaît clairement
que l'entourage de monsieur macron joue
un rôle d'une extrême précision dans la
mise en oeuvre des décisions pas
médiatiquement mais pas médiatiquement
mais j'ai évoqué la mise en oeuvre des
décisions c'est là que je disais à
l'instant que j'aurais dû jouer un rôle
plus important encore parce qu' un
gouvernement ça doit être tenu d'une
façon très étroite alors le premier
ministre joue son rôle et le produisent
par rapport au secrétaire général et
celui quand même qui représente le
pouvoir par rapport aux assemblées c'est
un rôle qui est tout à fait considérable
et françois fillon d'ailleurs un
jouissaient d'une très grande confiance
nous attendait à ce que nous entendions
bien nous nous voyons souvent ils
m'invitaient déjeuner de chaque mois et
balayons l'ensemble des choses et avec
ses collaborateurs tous les lundis nous
nous voyons également alors vous êtes
secrétaire général de l'elysée un temps
après vous devenez ministre de
l'intérieur en février depuis février
2000 on croira vous remplacer brice
hortefeux et là ça vaut correspond vous
êtes un homme d'ordre vous êtes un homme
de sécurité
et cette réputation ancien préfet et
vous prenez une circulaire une
circulaire sur l'immigration qui empêche
les étudiants étrangers de travailler en
même temps qu'ils font leurs études pour
regretter cette circulaire qui a fait
couler beaucoup d'encre ce que je
regrette dans cette affaire c'est de
n'avoir pas suffisamment à temps modifié
deux circulaires comme je fini par le
faire circuler l été mal comprise il
vous en est la traduction à l'instant
istréen a été très mal comprise
elle ne faisait que rappeler le droit
une disposition législative qui avait
été introduit par nicolas sarkozy
ministre de l'intérieur quelques années
plus tôt accord qui contrairement à
l'idée reçue et que vous venez de
traduire était une circulaire qui
avantage et les étudiants étrangers
puisque elle leur permettait à l'issue
de leurs études de d'avoir une
expérience professionnelle
mais ce que je disais dans ma circulaire
c'est qu'une fois l'expérience
professionnelle acquise ce qui était une
sorte de complément d'information eh
bien il n'y avait pas pour autant un
droit au séjour alors l'immigration
c'est un des grands sujets de nicolas
sarkozy et du rock pendant que vous êtes
ministre de l'intérieur et je vous
invite à regarder cette citation que
vous avez prononcé lors d'un discours
contrairement à ce que l'idéologie
relativiste de gauche pour nous toutes
les civilisations ne se valent pas
celles qui défendent l'humanité nous
paraissent plus avancée que celle qui la
nient alors c'est une phrase qui a fait
couler beaucoup d'encre dans ce discours
que vous avez prononcé lors d'un
colloque
qu'est ce que vous vouliez dire vouliez
dire que aujourd'hui on a tendance à
tout relativiser et que les
civilisations et bien il y en a qui sont
supérieures à d'autres
oui ce que je voulais dire c'est
qu'effectivement il y a des valeurs qui
pour un français qui est l'héritier de
son pays d'une vieille culture
qui a la chance de vivre dans un pays de
liberté de respect des idées de liberté
d'expression d'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes ce sont aussi des thèmes
qui complétait cette phrase il devrait
être évident de préférer cette
civilisation à d'autres civilisations
qui ni l'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes qui nie les libertés qui nie
l'humanité et ça me semblait aller
tellement de soi c'est est annonciateur
de ce qui s'est passé après c'est
évident je me souviens très bien que
quelques années plus tard lorsqu'il ya
eu les attentats contre charlie hebdo
les attentats du bataclan et ses rangs
tous les responsables politiques qui à
l'époque avait critiqué pour ne pas
respecter suffisamment les différences
de civilisation c'était eux venaient à
la télévision pour expliquer qu'il n'y
avait qu'une civilisation qui était la
nôtre ce qui n'était pas du tout le
point de vue que j'avais exprimé
d'accord il ya plusieurs civilisations
ceci dit je pense qu'un français devrait
rester fidèle aux caractéristiques de sa
propre civilisation alors avec nicolas
sarkozy vous avez connu le sommet oui
vous êtes parti très haut vous étiez
l'homme le plus puissant de france
c'est un journal avait dit ce qui était
faux mais c'est quoi et puis quand même
le pouvoir ça donne le vertige n'ont
parfois parce qu'avec nicolas sarkozy
vous avez aussi connu de l'autre versant
c'est là qu'en 2012 nicolas sarkozy
n'est pas réélu président de la
république ont connu l'échec
oui bien sûr l'échec alors c'est l'échec
politique mais s'est aussi d'une
certaine façon une chute qui est semé
d'embûches avec des affaires et qui
arrive alors bien évidemment mouammar
kadhafi yann affaire des comptes de
campagne des sondages du crédit lyonnais
des primes de cabinet beaucoup
d'affaires comme ça les affaires qui
sont pour certaines d'entre elles
pendante
est-ce que vous en boule et nicolas
sarkozy de vous avoir entraîné sur sept
emplois
ou est ce que vous attendiez pas à ce
que tout ça surgissent d'abord je ne
veux pas du tout un nicolas sarkozy qui
souffrent autant que moi d'ailleurs de
la façon dont ces prétendues affaires
sont traitées mais et c'est vrai et ça
fait partie de la violence que vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure je ne
m'attendais pas à ce déferlement
judiciaire d'abord on et puis ensuite
médiatique qui a entouré les initiatives
judiciaires
certaines de ces initiatives d'ailleurs
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire mais ne
sont pas nés comme ça et bizarrement
soleil ou quand je le dis sa nouvelle
berline s ont aidé au bon il y a eu je
le sais j'en suis absolument certain d
comment dire un complot politico
judiciaire au médiatique mais de la part
de qui moi je peux dire yves thréard
avec certitude que lorsque monsieur
valls était ministre de l'intérieur il
avait créé une structure
enfin il existait je ne sais pas si
c'est lui qui l'avait créé il existait
au sein de son cabinet une structure qui
se chargeait n'ont qu'à de votre cas
personnel m'a absolument et on a parlé
d'un cabinet noir de francs voilà on
n'est jamais utilisé cette expression
mais je dis qu'il y avait une structure
qui effectivement suivait avec le
concours de la police judiciaire un
certain nombre d'affaires distiller les
fuites
organisez l'orchestration médiatique
mais vous quittiez familier du pouvoir
qui l'aviez exercer qui connaissait tous
les rouages de la machine
vous attendiez pas ce que je n'attendais
retour de bâton je ne m'attendais pas à
cela parce que personnellement je n'ai
jamais eu de telles pratiques
vous n'avez jamais essayé de savoir ce
que je faisais vos adversaires et jamais
à d'interpol qui je n'ai jamais eu de la
sarkozie je n'ai jamais instrumentalisé
la police ou la justice jamais et
aujourd'hui dans quel état d'esprit vous
êtes vis-à-vis de toutes ces affaires là
j'ai de la tristesse de l'amertume
évidemment je vous dire que mon
appréciation sur la justice a un peu
évolué elle n'est plus aussi positive
qu'elle l'était vous avez le mézenc
politique tout le temps dit j'ai
confiance dans la justice de mon pays je
pense que l'expression est trop général
alors mais enfin écoutez la vie continue
ça nous a amené à rencontrer des gens
vous il avait plutôt une image d'homme
sérieux austère parfois un peu
janséniste de drôles de personnages ziad
takieddine alexandre djouhri mouammar
kadhafi tiens on va on va se rappeler un
petit souvenir
elle attendait ces retrouvailles depuis
huit ans leur coach aussi
sur le tarmac de l'aéroport de sofia ce
sont des embrassades passionnés derrière
les cinq infirmières et le médecin
bulgares les acteurs de leur libération
cécilia sarkozy la commissaire
européenne benita ferrero waldner qui
s'activent depuis deux ans sur ce
dossier enfin claude guéant secrétaire
général de l'elysée c'est obtenir la
décision de libération
c'était ça l'objectif
c'est ça qui a été très difficile
jusqu'à
les cons
on lit ce matin
6 heures
jusqu'où nous
alors là vous étiez donc à l'aéroport de
sofia vous avez joué un rôle dans cette
libération c'était un an à fin de l'été
2007 vous vous dites arrivé d'ailleurs à
l'elysée la libération est intervenue je
crois le 24 c'est ça le jeu 24 juillet
et je vois que c'était après une nuit
blanche pige au dessus par hasard
d'accord il ya eu des contreparties
cette affaire à cette libération dont
une écoute et je les dis la commission
denquête de l'assemblée nationale qui
s'est réunie devant laquelle j'ai
témoigné en décembre de l'année 2007
il n'y a pas eu de contrepartie
politique ou financière ou quoi que ce
soit il y a eu un geste de notre part je
les dis ce jour là qui était en réponse
à une sollicitation libyenne que la
france aide la libye à mettre en service
l'hôpital de benghazi gigantesque
structure de 12 cents lits qui est
installé d'ailleurs juste en face de
l'hôpital où avaient été traités les
enfants malades du sida et que les
libyens faute de compétences médicales
et managériale n'arrivait pas à mettre
en route et là effectivement la france a
fait un effort qui a coûté une petite
trentaine de millions est ce que il
fallait absolument libérer ces
infirmières bulgares alors que la france
était quand même pas complètement
concerné par cette affaire même si elle
était tout à fait condamnable
7 je veux dire la détention ces
infirmières fréquenté kadhafi est ce que
c'était une bonne chose finalement
vous l'avez vu souvent vous je les ai
vus plusieurs fois effectivement la bd
ou gelée vue
à tripoli
parfois sous sa tente je crois que
c'était même toujours sous sa tente
parce qu'ils avaient en dehors de son
bureau dans lequel n'est jamais pénétré
une tente dans laquelle ils recevaient
les gens et quand on est un homme de
pouvoir on est obligés de fréquenter des
gens comme ça alors kadhafi les chefs
d'état oui mais djouhri takeddine la
question que vous posez concernant deux
personnes est une question qui me
semble-t-il est plus large dans un état
la question se pose de savoir si on se
repose entièrement sur les structures de
l'état ou bien si on accepte de recevoir
des gens qui peuvent vous dire des
choses qui peuvent vous apporter des
éléments sur l'état d'un pays étranger
sur ce qui s'y passe etc
vous êtes un pressage obliger un mail je
crois que c'est utile
on peut choisir de ne voir que les
diplomates mais regardez ce qui se passe
aux etats unis le pouvoir américain est
entièrement organisée autour de ces
mutants que le relais que représentent
les hommes d'affaires américains qui
sillonne le monde on peut pas gouverner
en totale transparence tout le temps il
faut parfois des coulisses des corridors
qui sont un peu son char ge servette
ouah je veux dire que ce réussir ce type
de relation n'était pas dissimulé enfin
oui on a suffisamment parlé d'ailleurs
un mais et on n'est pas obligé de tout
dire quand on gouverne c'est vrai c'est
vrai on n'est pas obligé de dire tous
les matins voilà ce que j'ai fait et
voilà les contacts etc
et ce n'est pas ne pas tout dire c'est
pas c'est pas forcément de la
dissimulation et aujourd'hui claude
guéant dont vous avez été cité dans
plein d'affaires comment on vit tout ça
quelques années après c'est compliqué on
le vit mal vous êtes seul
maintenant vous êtes un homme seul où
vous êtes en moi je gardais des amis
j'en ai trouvé d'autre mais aussi je ne
veux pas embarrasser des gens qui ont
été mes amis qui pourraient souffrir de
ma proximité
nicolas sarkozy y continuez à vous
appeler au téléphone alors nicolas
sarkozy
n'a plus le droit de me parler il a plus
droit de vous parler il à moi je le vois
aller loin dans le contrôle judiciaire
dont il est l'objet n'a pas grande de
parler donc nous ne nous parlons plus
pour ma part j'en souffre souffrait de
sa baby nord est et pour d'autres que
vous avez fréquenté qui ont été vos
collaborateurs ou des ministres ait
encore des contacts avec cerveau dont
certaines souffrent pour certains
d'entre eux j'imagine que oui j'imagine
nous leur en voulez certains pourraient
se montrer plus amicaux ça c'est certain
mais enfin bon côté c'est la vie c'est
la vie
je n'oublie pas que la contrepartie de
ce dont je souffre ça a été de
formidables expériences au service des
français ça voulait garder gravé en
mémoire à sa séquence de 6 et les
français quand vous les croisez dans la
rue qui vous reconnaissent évidemment
puisque vous avez été un personnage
public est ce que il vous félicite tout
le temps en a qui détourne le regard
le temps passe donc j'imagine que mon
image s'oublier un peu même si vous la
restituer par des émissions comme celle
que vous organisez en ce moment
distraire mais
je dois dire que jamais je n'ai été
l'objet depuis 2012 sa fille de 8 ans
déjà de manifestations agressives sur la
voie publique
au contraire un très souvent des gens
m'abordent pour me dire leur sympathie
cet été encore en vacances je me
souviens c'était émouvant
quelqu'un vient me voir et me dit
monsieur je loue salut je vais vous
saluer vous avez été le meilleur me
lisent à l'intérieur que nous ayons
jamais eu
bon je suis pas sûr que ça soit
appréciée par les autres lisent à
l'intérieur notamment l'un d'entre eux
qui est devenu président de la
république ensuite mais enfin ça m'a
fait plaisir
d'accord coptes allons vous retournez
vous auriez fait la même chose
vous auriez fréquenter les mêmes
personnes vous auriez tr td même affaire
vous auriez des nicolas sarkozy a même
façon il fallait faire bien sûr et toute
façon on ne refait pas les choses
et puis je suis pas un calculateur moi
j'étais le collaborateur de nicolas
sarkozy
je lui étais complètement dévoué je lui
reste complètement le royal évidemment
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour ce qu'il a
fait et j'espère que les français son
image ayant été aussi parfois un peu
écornée et redirons leur admiration leur
satisfaction leur reconnaissance de ce
qu'il a fait alors on est parti dans
cette division
je vous ai posé la question le service
de l'état où l'exercice du pouvoir
finalement vous avez aimé l'exercice du
pouvoir
oui mais comme moyen oui c'est eux c'est
tout à fait passionnant moyens pour
changer la société pour changer les
choses
claude guéant s'il y avait dans votre
parcours politique jusqu'à présent
quelque chose a changé ça serait quoi ce
que j'aurais dû faire ou ne pas faire
voulait dire ce que j'aurais dû faire ou
ne pas faire
ben j'ai fait une erreur grave
c'était en 2012
j'ai été candidat aux élections
législatives dans les hauts-de-seine
j'ai perdu la boule bio et j'aurai à
gauche qu'à droite d'ailleurs
oui et j'aurais dû
rester fidèle à mon premier engagement
qui était d'être candidat ailleurs qui
m'avait été proposé par l'appareil du
parti ou journée sans doute été lue de
façon aux rafales c'était dans les îles
est d'accord merci claude guéant c'est
moi qui vous remercie extraire
[Musique]